[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir tous nos amis
bonsoir mais nounours où vas-tu avec ce
cartable à l'école pas trop bon le seul
le hip hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop on
l'a encore un cube on dirait la tour
eiffel bonsoir nicolas bonsoir pas
preneur battu avec ce cartable à l'école
il n'est jamais trop tard pour apprendre
brown on tue pas comme papa tipa prône
elle et nous si on y allait aussi à
l'école oui mais alors c'est nicole toi
de nous au tableau noir à l'école pas
besoin d'être grand
juste quatre cinq ans il suffit tout
simplement de se conduire gentiment à
l'école
mais aussi sur un bon et tout ce qu'elle
le croit et il m'a tapé très fort quand
tout le monde est content on est en
famille quand on veut s'amuser quand je
lis les connes à la grande maison il m'a
des crayons où ils ont fait de beaux
bateaux où l'on chante des chansons à la
gentille école des filles et deux
garçons
on y apprend qu'ils le sont on joue avec
des ballons volés les créations
spéciales et je vais pas cantonné parce
que c'est à l'école
quand on est des amis des goûts et des
petits et qu'ils conservent aussi quand
il aimera tout ça vous dieu qui veulent
l'école
il aime aussi aller pour l'idée calculé
rivet pour dessiner tomber ben ali ont
ce merveilleux l'école
j'aimerais y retourner pour de bon non
nous irons quand nous serons plus grands
oui papa ne l'a promis pourvu qu'il ne
me demande pas les effleure deux fois la
nuit de noces denis gronier bol de nuit
les petits la j'éteins la lumière fêtes
de bourg bonne nuit des enfants allez
vite vous coucher car il faut se lever
de bonne heure pour aller à l'école
on s'en va pas trop en routière nounours
bonne nuit faite de peaux
[Musique]
avant